all right all right all right said I
said offer little little little little
we're only rule here only loo-li loo-li
loo-li loo-li loo-li [ __ ] i don't of
this what the [ __ ] are you doing um I
don't know if this is supposed to be
slightly erotic or what's happening oh
oh oh it's so realistic I can blow these
I'm blowing so good
Oh where's my B to blow controls where
they goddamn is nice oh they're over
here
wrong side ha ha I'm so stupid
oh hey up there wrong but okay I'll take
that
hello oh wait no you're not the audience
actually you're kind of in the exact
same places the audience so hello
everybody my name is Margo Haut
goddamnit
hello copy just gonna keep it down hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to job simulator I finally got
this all working I had loaded up so he
forgotten what he was supposed to say
and I already got these over here so
okay anyway so I am okay so I just drive
and let's ask oh shut up
as if I have time for this [ __ ] you
stay out of my way I'll stay out of your
way we'll both have a good time yay
where am I human will go to an accurate
simulation of office worker uh-huh okay
so look at this board for instructions
Oh God take paper when ready if I want
to do that whenever oh here okay I get
to work like we traditionally Stewart
Oh God Oh God everything's fine
for you and cooperate oh lordy oh lordy
Hey look the Nerds
not that one this one by God's magic oh
my god
take it enough someone stop me diabetes
gonna get me ah you're here forever
you're goddamn right I am who is that
who's be making noise over there I'm
trying to concentrate with my cough yeah
got it yeah let me just get a little bit
of that tasty goodness I like my coffee
like I like my soul black good enough
no those devil foods oh god what
happened there I am okay what take paper
when ready I already took the pic hey
[ __ ] bag wake up is the most important
facet of the office humans and safety
being a close second I should probably
put the safety straps around my arms
that would be a smart thing to do but I
ain't that boink boink
yeah okay please type your password
hello
Oh God Oh God okay shut up I did it yeah
yeah yeah in efficient form of
communication
um is this Bruce Almighty holy [ __ ] does
your life sucks
goddamn freedom of inbox zero okay weird
weird
hello ass who threw this stand up who
did it look guy it wasn't me it
certainly wasn't me I don't even know
how to throw I don't even have arms just
hands floating in mid-air I'm the guy
from super smash bros okay ah ah paper
one ready I was messing around with the
computer the whole time
supervisors oh yeah
new positions yours oh boy take this
boss Hey sorry didn't mean to do that
thank you
Wow human climbing the ranks and here
comes Buzz but looks like he's got more
work for you crap but I don't want more
work I got a piece of paper god damn it
why do I need these it's the same damn
thing [ __ ] you boss bottom boss but
thank you oh god if you belong being so
I'm here to give you your first half of
it so look through your resumes and find
two balls to hire
oh no I wanted to caress your chin or
grundle I don't know if that was which I
don't know huh Oh make sure you take the
best for the job you got it boss
I'm on it where's my goddamn resumes I'm
the really tall human oh down here oh
good let me just sort through this with
so much care [ __ ] this guy how about no
this guy's green I like him already
hired yeah did it hipster but what was
that you Oh with any job ah I am utterly
confused I didn't know you guys were
here our song would have been a little
more polite looks okay what now
take paper goddamn it with it I know I
get it I get it
you see that what this isn't good
numbers okay you got it boss I know what
I know I know how to solve it I know
what to do oh god no this is horrifying
it's too much on hot sauce Oh God aah
wait no hang on yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
ah ha ok yay business all right whoa
hello what until fully legit revenue
book ok uh alright here we go gourmet
chef that comes next
that's not my job yet but it's gonna be
goddamn papers each time for lunch and
midday humans would interact with
primitive robots known as vending
machines to obtain uh-huh oh thank you
for the money is this the only pay that
I'm gonna get for the rest of my life
all right
BAM I want me some triangles please
Oh Oh do I need to like do it how do i
ah oh god I hate the bag candy bar
am I gonna die I'm a human
I don't do with plastic yeah looks like
it's okay we're good enough I guess
take it [ __ ] oh why am I on my knees
oh why is life forsaken me work fine
over here what in your computer and
check out these hilarious pictures oh
okay
how's hot shits uh-oh no memes Thank You
forward to your presentation today Oh
business we did in the last week oh so
boss buck wants you to do a presentation
you'll need to make some slides time to
learn about an ancient human technique
called winging it organizing this
program in your computer but I just put
flappy Bob in I wanna do this god I
don't actually work I'm so stupid
what oh you're not talking about okay
all right let's do this how do we do
this this looks borderline unreadable
motivational ISM okay transition is
cheesy overview is visual with memes
lots of memes dramatic deceitful and
then finally ending with professional
and called action all right I won't oh
oh good okay I'm ready let's see it
everyone gather round I'll stand up
or everyone Batum you ready to go
through this presentation you know a
Boston clicker you got it huh
whoa what the hell is that okay
memes ha ha ha yeah mind if I keep this
it was really business thank you
why'd you leave me with your dildo
alright friend stand up [ __ ] you I want
your mustache you bring it over to me
hello who are you
hey human bot number one zero one one
zero is retiring tomorrow I wanted to
give them a parting gift everyone's
pitching in why you give me something
you'd like to contribute uh uh what does
this do
you're hired how about that yeah yeah
it's said you're hired
you think you could to go with this oh
my god I already did this uh I don't
have to I don't have time for this I got
I got work to do man love letter love it
love it
no [ __ ] I emotion you okay good enough
the emoji says it all there you go
no problem happy to do it you have a
nice day now I'm gonna be here pulling
this stupid piece of paper that's gonna
give me more assignments yeah things
aren't going too well we need to find a
couple paths we can might go okay all
right didn't I just hire this guy oh
well you won't miss it then there's no
idea what he's going through
okay uh yeah too fancy for artists don't
you kind of need that to survive is that
like getting breast implants Dinklage
M's
no sorry I'm not really sorry I actually
don't care we humans don't have jobs
anymore all right goodbye in the office
co-workers would confer no I don't think
that makes sense and I don't even follow
sports you [ __ ]
how about you take your kids can I have
this thank you I want this can I have
this can I have these can I have these
can I burn these what can I do with
these what lovely kids you have do I
have any kids
oh yeah I do look at this
it's adorable look at me look at my life
I know it's so sweet
[ __ ] off all right whatever what next
what do I got I'm ready
HUP I said hey look I've got some papers
I need you to shred it has to be you for
legal reasons here just look in the case
everything okay but the money why do I
need to shred the money that seems like
exactly what I should have yeah but I'm
as if I stick my hand in their eyes
buzzing it's buzzing so nicely what
happens if I stick my whole head in here
oh it's terrifying oh my god okay okay I
guess sorry okay cool there's all that
shooting out laughs poor guy's office I
no one cares
are the money I like money
yeah here's the other thing I just found
out that for insurance reasons you can't
actually have this much stuff in your
cubicle you're going to need to know but
I cherish all these random devices I'm
not getting rid of my stapler God knows
what all right fine goodbye no happiness
left in my life no need to drink when
I'm probably gonna die soon I didn't
even like get him again with world's my
average worker no I'm not done yet no
hang on I'm not done I got more stuff to
do I don't even know who this is
Oh way to hire him I said I hired that
guy all right some of this about you
you're right I don't need to know the
time I love working so much I'll never
leave is this okay yeah we're doing good
guys - you all right goodbye whoa sorry
it wasn't me okay goodbye now doodles
hi here's the thing boss spot needs to
go away for a while and you've been
doing a really good job oh I'd like to
offer you a promotion
oh oh
why isn't this working
why isn't it working it's perfect
oh okay why is there a but never mind
then forget I said anything
hello what do we have here oh the owners
of what oh yeah how am I supposed to
just keep there oh hello Saturday yes it
has you [ __ ] come on I wanna go home
and we have human bodily needs I need to
go home and look at porn you robots
wouldn't understand you don't understand
us
you don't understand humanity you're not
under dad anything
oh please eat your selection what is
this oh my exit burrito I have a funny
feeling I know how this gonna end
Oh what the right what did it say
something out there oh okay hello humans
grab a cartridge from the tree yeah yeah
work oh it's gold get that a good no
okay
that's golden delightful but anyway so
that is all for job simulator for now
that's the office World Report's and
there's more versions of job simulator
in the game but let me know if you guys
want to see them and let me know what
other virtual reality games you want me
to play a humble 5 in the future thanks
again everybody so much for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye Oh what the hell where'd you
come from you back up there buddy okay